Hello, everyone.
Welcome to my lecture,
Growth Divisions of
CNS, CNS representing
Central Nervous System.
Let's get started.
In this lecture,
we're going to learn
the major
organizations of the
human's nervous
system, as well as the
major functions of
each subdivision.
This is truly a
global overview.
Showing here on the
right, you can see it's
almost like a family
tree. So we're going
to cover this entire
tree with detailed
structures later on in
the next semester for
the Papam I. We have
not only the Neural
Anatomy Lab, but also
Neural Anatomy Lectures
for the entire first
block in January. So
over here, don't be
too stressed about the
detailed structures
since you're going to
learn those details
in the next semester.
and my requirement
for this lecture is in
the detailed session
objectives in the
cpg so make sure you
look at the cpg and if
it's anything not
very clear this book
notice essentials of
the human brain this
is available at our
library with an electronic
version so you can
click on the link
here to read the
book. Chapter three is
relevant to this
lecture. This is very
helpful. So highly
recommend this book.
So if you have time
to read it during
the break, it will
set a very good
foundation for next
semester's lectures.
Highly recommend.
Okay, let's look at
some fun facts about
brains first of all
you know the brains are
bilaterally symmetric
right you have the
two left and right
hemispheres and the
material feels soft
and like gelatin when
they're fresh of course
when you're looking
at the cadavers when
we take out the brains
then the brains actually
touch feels like
rubber pretty rough
that's because of the
fixation and the brains
are surrounded by
meninges and the
skull to protect them
and there's very
interesting gender and age
differences for the
for the weight of the
brain as you can see
here the females are
green and males are
blue you can see very
clearly that the you
know brain mass actually
increases with
age but it kind of
plateaued when we are
in the adolescent age
and it doesn't change
much in the adulthood
and there's a clear
difference between
male and female in
terms of their absolute
weight but when you
look at you know the
brain weight divided
by body weight you
know normalized by
the body weight the
females actually
has a little more uh
advantageous here you
can see in the earlier
year and also later
in life, they're
slightly higher in
terms of the proportion
of the body weight. So
if anyone tells you,
hey, males are
generally smarter than
females, you could
counter by this fact.
The nervous system can
be divided into the
central nervous system,
CNS and peripheral
nervous system PNS
so that's the biggest
categorization with
the CNS you can see the
color code is red or
pinkish red comprised
of a brain and spinal
cord with the *****
color coded as blue
you can see the nerves
as well as ganglia so
here for the CNS you
know brain also
comprised you can further
divide it into the
forebrain which is the
cerebrum and bedded
inside underneath the
cerebrum is a diencephalon
putting together as
a forebrain and then
you also have the
cerebellum that's
underneath the cerebrum and
then you would have a
brainstem brainstem is
in front of the
cerebellum connecting the
forebrain with the
spinal cord for the
peripheral nervous
system all of these blue
like the nerves are
part of the peripheral
nervous system even
including the cranial
nerves so the cranial
nerves are coming out of
the cranium you know
you can you can imagine
it's from the skull
originated and then
coming out to reach
the peripheral tissues
so they're still part
of the peripheral
nervous system even
though it's cranial nerves
and the spinal nerves
are stemming from
the spinal cord right
so different segments
of the spinal cord
you have spinal
nerves you also have
ganglia so ganglia is
where the cell body
is concentrated so
the nerves are formed
by the axons of this
of the neurons and
the ganglias are the
cell bodies, including
sensory motor
neurons, as well as
the autonomic neurons.
So the sensory neurons,
the very typical
example that I can think
of is called dorsal
root ganglia, DRG. So
the dorsal root ganglia
is located right
outside the dura of the
spinal nerve, very
close to the spinal
cord, but it's still
outside the CNS. It's
considered part of the
***** and so there are
sensory or motor neurons
located inside the
spinal cord or the
brain so uh you know so
the sensory motor
neurons is part of cns
part of the pns
similarly the autonomic
neurons also have you
know the preganglionic
neurons located inside
the cns and postganglionic
neurons are usually
located in the pns
and there's also a
enteric nervous system
is kind of special
i put a star there
because some resources
consider enteric
nervous system as part
of the autonomics but
then others consider
it's an independent
separate system so
enteric nervous system
are located inside
the gut so that's why
it's a typical pns
there's one exception
about the ganglia
called basal ganglia
so this basal ganglia
some sources call
it as a basal nuclei
because it's actually
inside the cns considered
part of the cns
rather than you know
other ganglia are all
the pns structures
we're going to talk
more in this next slide
the tissues in the cns
can be divided into
gray matter and white
matter so the gray
matter in the natural
color would be
grayish and darker than
the color of the white
matter so gray matter
is where the cell
bodies and dendroids
located versus the
white matter has the
myelin sheaths you know
large axons and the
myelin sheaths are
high fat so that's
why the color is white
showing here though
you can see the
gray matter is actually
a lighter color
compared to the
white matter is a
bluish black so this
is because of the
myelin stain to
bring out the myelin
really the myelinated
fibers of the
white matter
so the gray matter
can you know the most
commonly seen is called
cortex right you see
the contours located
in the cerebrum and
cerebellum and less
commonly you would have
nucleus or nuclei as
a pleural and then
you would also see
very rarely just one
called basal ganglia so
the basal ganglia you
know, uses the old
term that, you know,
ganglia is supposed to
be peripheral nervous
system tissues, but
now used just as, you
know, this one exception
as basal ganglia.
So some people do call
it a basal nuclei.
It's the same thing.
White matter referring
to a bunch of
myelinated exons, right?
So we can tell whether
there's this structure
is white matter
by these telltale
terms like tract,
lenticularis, fasciculus,
lamniscus, peduncle,
all of these actually
meaning something
like a small bundle
and these bundles of
fibers or bundles
of axons are highly
myelinated And so here,
you know, just from
the term optic tract,
you would be able
to tell, okay, this
is the white matter.
So in the spinal
cord, it's the same
thing. You also see
the white matter,
which stained darker,
and the gray matter,
which stained, you
know, very light.
so basically the
gray matter is also
where the neuron
cell body is located
and also the
non-myelinated
dendrites but the
white matter is where
the myelinated
large fibers located
besides the gray
matter and white
matter there are also
a bunch of spaces
in the central
nervous system these
spaces including the
ventricles aqueduct
sulcus and cisterns
so showing here
you know between the
two different views
are the ventricles you
can see the lateral
ventricle you know
pretty big one this is
a side view and then
this is the anterior
posterior view you can
see the two very big
lateral ventricles
and also there are you
know four ventricles
total so the two
lateral ventricles that's
two and then we also
have the third
ventricles which is here
showing the middle
and then over here
is this one that's
the third ventricle
and then the fourth
ventricles is actually
going along the
brainstem so you can
see here that's the
fourth ventricle
so in between the
ventricles there's
also aqueduct so
aqueduct is a tubing
in between the third
and fourth ventricle
so this is our aqueduct
connecting the third
and fourth ventricle
and you can see here
the fourth ventricle
has some holes and so
the two lateral ones
and then also there's a
center one that goes
along the spinal spinal
cord central canal so
it's connected with
the central canal here
and all the ventricles
are connected so the
lateral ventricles
between the two lateral
ventricles, they
both actually connect
with the third ventricle
over here called
the, like over here
showing, that would be
the interventricular
foramen. So you're going
to learn all of these
next semester, you know,
at the first month,
first block during
the neuroanatomy lab
and then during that
neuroanatomy lectures.
So don't worry too
much about the details.
I just kind of wanted
to plant a seed here.
So these ventricles and
aqueduct are
all connected.
And inside are filled
with fluids. So the
fluid is called
cerebrospinal fluids or CSF.
So CSF actually is
produced by the ventricle
linings called
choroid plexus. So the
production of the CSF
is inside the ventricle,
and then it goes
outside along, you know,
these holes, right,
like these holes goes
to the subarachnoid
space, which is between
the arachnoid matter
and pure matter. so
this is the subarachnoid
space is filled by
the css so the entire
brain and spinal cord
are actually um you
know all the brain
tissue the cns tissues
are hanging inside or
floating inside the
cerebrospinal fluids
which is helping to
reduce the vibration you
know producing the
protection to the CMS.
We've learned about
the ventricles and
aqueduct in the last
slide. Once again, you
can see here the two very
big lateral ventricles
separated by this
fairly thin membrane
-like structure called
septum pellucidum.
And then also we
see this very big
space here. is a big
longitudinal fissure
that's a crack in
between the two
hemispheres, separating
the two hemisphere
left and right.
And we also have
the large lateral
sulcus located here.
So the lateral sulcus
on this side over
here. The lateral sulcus
is also called the
lateral fissure,
separating the frontal lobe
at the top and the
temporal lobe at the
bottom and so the last
one the cisterns are
formed in between
the brain tissues and
the and the skull
so you have multiple
cisterns inside the brain
so like these cracks
here all the cisterns
filled with the csf
So in this slide,
you can see the third
ventricle. You could
still see the two lateral
ventricles, just that
they are much smaller
since this is a different
cut of the brain
slice. And then you also
see a very small hole
here. That's our
aqueduct located at the
midbrain. And then you
would also see these
cisterns right so these
are the large space in
between the brain
tissues and the skull so
that's the spaces well
we mentioned about
different directions
like anterior posterior
superior inferior now
let's get the clear
understanding about the
directions of the CNS
so showing here you can
see for a fish it has
a longitudinal axis right
so this longitudinal
axis can divide the
fish into different
areas so anterior and
rostral meaning toward
the nose and then
posterior and caudal
meaning toward the
tail so and then
the longitudinal
axis dividing the
top as superior or
dorsal and then the
bottom part is inferior
ventral. So this is
consistent among not only
fish, but also most
majority of the mammals,
you know, the quadrupeds.
They always have
these directions like
consistently defined.
However, for our
humans, we actually have
two different axis.
You can see the brain
has this longitudinal
axis that's parallel
to the ground, but
because we're walking,
stand up, right? So
our spinal cord, our
brainstem and spinal
cord actually have a
different axis, goes along
the body. So this axis
has almost 80 degree
angle from the brain
axis. So we call this
cephalic flexure.
Cephalic flexure making
the terms of directions
are very confusing.
So for the brain,
we still have very
similar direction terms,
like the anterior is
the same as racial,
meaning toward the
nose, right? And then
posterior is the same as
caudal, meaning toward
the back of the brain.
And then superior
and dorsal as well as
inferior and ventral
are still the
same definition
as we have in the fish.
But at the spinal
cord and brainstem,
so along this
different axis,
now anterior and
ventral is actually the
same thing instead of
rostral. So anterior
is meaning in front
of the body, right?
So in front of the
body, it's underneath,
you know, this
relative to this
longitudinal axis,
it's underneath.
So anterior is equal
with the ventral
aspects and the
posterior is equaling
the dorsal aspects.
So this is the same
thing for the brainstem
and spinal cord.
Now, the rostral
is actually defined
by toward the nose
or toward the brain,
and then the caudal,
meaning toward the
tailbone or toward
the lumbar region.
So, in summary, in
the brain, you still
have the dorsal and
superior equal together,
but then in the
brainstem and spinal
cord, the dorsal is
meaning posterior. So
that is a different
definition. So that's
why in the brainstem
and spinal cord, we
use a lot of the term
like racial and caudal
instead of using, you
know, anterior and
posterior. So that
is the general rule.
and there are three
planes of sectioning so
when we are trying
to slice the brain we
could do three different
directions you know
x y and z right so the
first way of cutting
is along the longitudinal
fissure so the
same way as if we cut
the brain into the two
left and right hemispheres
so this uh if we
cut it right in the
midline we call it mid
sagittal view if we
cut the brain like away
like parallel
to the midline
these would be
the parasatical
slices so that's
one direction
and then the
second direction
for the horizontal
that would be
you know like
this longitudinal
axis, you know, along
this or parallel to
this longitudinal axis.
So this would be our
horizontal slices.
So we slice the brain
parallel to this longitudinal
axis. And remember,
there is a cephalic
flexure here, right?
So for the brainstem
and spinal cord, the
longitudinal axis is
this direction so it
would be confusing if
we call it horizontal
sections so instead
we would call it axial
sections so the axial
sections would be along
this longitudinal axis
to slice it this way
so this is our horizontal
or axial sections
and then the third
one is you know we
slice the brain
perpendicular to this
longitudinal axis. So
basically, it's this
way, you know, going
from the front to the
back, you know, this is
anterior posteriorly.
If we make the
cut this way, then
these are coronal
sections. Again, for the
brainstem, if we're
cutting perpendicular
to our longitudinal
planes, these are called
transverse sections.
So transverse, or
we can call it cross
sections. They're
just not the exact
plane as either coronal
or horizontal. So for
brainstem and spinal
cord, they're just
called differently.
But here is our X, Y,
and Z different cutting.
let's take a close
look at the major
structures of the cns
as we mentioned before
the forebrain brain
stem and cerebellum
is forming the brain
right and then we
have this is our
brain and then we have
a long spinal cord
goes along the uh you
know from cervical
to the lumbar region
And so the brain is
formed by the forebrain,
brainstem, and
cerebellum. So the
forebrain is this
pinkish structure here.
So this entire area
is called forebrain.
So within the forebrain
is actually formed
by the two cerebral
hemispheres, or we also
call it cerebrum. So
that's the pink color.
you also see this green
color right here in
the middle buried
deep in the core that
is our diencephalon so
showing here you know
since it's green i'm
going to use this
green lines showing
here the diencephalon
actually have three
major structures you can
see more clearly in
this mid-sagittal view.
So the center one is
called the thalamus,
and then you also
have the ones that
underneath the thalamus
is called hypothalamus,
and then you also have
the structure that's
kind of on top,
and also behind the
thalamus, that's the
epithelium. So these three
structures forming
the diencephalon here.
And so both the
diencephalon and the
cerebral hemisphere,
also called cerebrum,
forming the forebrain.
So that is the
entire structure.
This is our forebrain.
And the brainstem
is the structure
connecting the
forebrain with
the spinal cord.
So it's here
in this kind of
purplish color.
So the brainstem is
when we look at close
closely enough it has
three structures too
so this is our midbrain
and then the midbrain
has the two bumps
here that's kind of
give you the landmark
and then the big belly
that is our basal
pons so this is the
second part of the
brainstem is called pons.
And then the third
part is called
medulla. So medulla
is much more skinny.
It's connecting,
you know, very
smoothly to the spinal
cord down below.
So that's our brainstem,
the three major
structures.
And then you also have
the cerebellum. So
the cerebellum is
located behind the
brainstem and underneath
the cerebellum. And
so the cerebellum also
have two hemispheres.
It's called cerebellar
hemispheres.
And spinal cord is the
most straightforward
central nervous system
structure in the
clinical setting you would
rarely see the stained
sections but you would
more likely seeing
these mri images so
over here again this
is a mid-sagittal view
of the brain and then
so on the right side
this is the mid-sagittal
view of the brain and
the spinal cord so
you should be able to
identify the forebrain
which is you know the
cerebral hemisphere
plus the diencephalon
so this is our
diencephalon right in
the middle or the core
and then you have
the two big cerebral
hemispheres so
together it's called
forebrain and then you
also have the brain
stem uh which is here
right the three major
structures midbrain
palms and medulla
and you also have the
cerebellum underneath
the cerebrum and
behind the brain stem
and then of course you
have the spinal cord
so spinal cord is
this long structure
that's extended from
the brain stem so over
here same thing you
should be able to
identify all of these
brain structures now
let's zero in to take
a closer look at the
brain we can see
several major landmarks
separating brain
into different parts
first of all the
longitudinal fissure
separating the brain
into the left and right
hemisphere And then
with these other ones
like central sulcus
or central fissure,
lateral sulcus or lateral
fissure, dividing
the cerebral
hemispheres into
different lobes.
and we also have
this transverse
fissure which is
separating the
forebrain from
the cerebellum
all of these major
landmarks separating
you know the brain into
different divisions
when we peel off the
meninges we could
see much clearer in
terms of these sulci
and gyra so this is
our central sulcus
right we mentioned
in the previous slide
so this is a very deep
groove and then uh
the the other one is
lateral sulcus so these
uh sulci are really uh
important in terms of
dividing the brain
especially cerebral
hemisphere into different
subdivisions. And then
these ridge regions,
so this one in front of
the central sulcus
is called pre-central
gyrus, and then the
ridge that's behind the
central sulcus, that
would be the post-central
gyrus. So those ridge
regions, you know the
gyri, are very important
to mediate different
functions so we're
going to go through
some major functions
in the following slides
as you can see here
the central sulcus
and lateral sulcus
dividing the cerebral
hemisphere into frontal
lobe and parietal
lobe there is another
one here showing
from the occipital
notch and parietal
occipital sulcus kind
of have a hypothetical
line to dividing the
occipital lobe from
the temporal lobe
all right let's look
at the cerebral
hemisphere lobe by lobe
The first one is the
frontal lobe. So frontal
lobe, as you recall,
is actually defined
by this central sulcus.
So this entire area
before the central
sulcus is a frontal lobe.
So in this frontal
lobe, the most important
functions are several.
So first of all, there
is a planning and
executive function. So
basically, you know,
what you're planning to
do, this is the frontal
lobe. And there's also
a very important
structure called primary
motor cortex. So the
primary motor cortex is
also, is located at
the precentral gyrus,
meaning before the
central sulcus, right? so
precentral gyrus here
and basically it's
controlling all the
voluntary movement of the
whole body so let's say
if you want to drink
a cup of coffee you
have to you know pour it
add whatever ingredients
and then bring
the cup to your mouth
and then drink it
right all of these
motor functions are
actually mediated by
this motor the primary
motor cortex at the
precentral gyrus.
There is also another
area that is very very
important called
prefrontal cortex. So the
prefrontal cortex
here is related very
importantly related to
the personality and it
produced that inhibition
type of function. For
example, if we need
to go to the bathroom
and then you know the
social situation doesn't
allow us, we're going
to hold it, right?
So if there is prefrontal
cortex damage, a
lot of times people,
you know, the adults
would not having that
type of inhibition and do
something that's not
appropriate in the
public. So the famous
patient, his name is
Phineas Gage. He's the one
that helped us discover
the function of this
prefrontal cortex.
And he's
actually defining
this frontal lobe for us.
Fenus Gage had a really
horrible accident.
He was a railroad
worker. And at one
time, one of the
railroad one of the rails
like a stick up and
then this metal bar
crossed his face you
know penetrating from
his cheek and then
exiting from the top
of his skull and
completely damaged his
prefrontal cortex you
can see here an image
shown in the Harvard
Courtway Library
this Mr. Gage, he actually
survived, luckily,
actually lived for
more than 10 years
after this horrible
accident. However, his
mother, his family
members all said he's
becoming a different
person altogether.
Now let's look at
the parietal lobe.
As we mentioned
before, the central
sulcus is a landmark
separating the
frontal lobe from
the parietal lobe.
So the parietal lobe,
one of the major,
major structure is
called postcentral
gyrus and this is behind
the central sulcus,
right? So postcentral
gyrus. It has
the primary somatosensory
cortex and this
somatosensory cortex
receives all the
sensory information
from the entire body.
In the parietal
lobe, this area is
called the sensory
association area.
It helps with the
spatial awareness.
The vision function
is located at the
back of the brain
called occipital lobe.
And right here,
alongside two banks,
you know, the
upper and lower
banks of this calcary
sulcus is called,
it's the primary
visual cortex.
And the auditory
cortex is actually
located in the
temporal lobe. So as we
mentioned before,
the temporal lobe
is below the lateral
sulcus and has the
auditory primary
cortex as well as
some very important
limbic structures.
The two very important
limbic structures
are called amygdala
and hippocampus.
As you can see here,
this is a parasitical
brain slice showing
the hippocampus.
It's a long
structure at the
medial temporal lobe.
and also amygdala
looks like an
almond shape.
Both are very important
limbic structures.
Hippocampus is
very important
for learning and memory,
and amygdala is a very
important structure
for emotional sensation
like fear or anger.
If you have lesions
there, then the person
will not have the
normal fearful response.
I'd like to
highlight some
language areas that
not just belong
to one lobe
but it's a very
prominent at the
exterior side of the
cerebral hemispheres.
As you can see here we
have Broca's area and
Wernicke's area. So
Broca's area is mainly
at the frontal lobe
and Wernicke's area
is mainly at the
temporal lobe and part
of the parietal lobe.
Broca's area at
the frontal lobe,
that is close to
the primary motor
cortex at the
precentral gyrus.
And so you can remember
that Broca's area
is causing, you know,
the lesion to this
area is causing production
of spoken language
deficit. So the person
would be able to
understand another
person's spoken language,
but just cannot respond
as they want. So
they know it in the
brain, they know the
answer, just could not
say it out smoothly.
As we mentioned earlier,
the Wernicke's area
is at the temporal
lobe, maybe extended
a little bit to the
parietal lobe too, at
the superior temporal
gyrus. So this area
lesion will cause
Wernicke's aficia, which
is also called receptive
official that means
the person cannot
understand the conversation
so they can speak
but what they talked
about does not usually
make sense so they
have problem with
comprehending the language
and making effective
communications but
they can talk so they
don't have the fluency
issue but they have
you know their word
just doesn't make sense
i'm including links
of the two videos
here that you guys can
look at it online and
to see really what the
characteristics of
these two different
types of aphasia. Very
distinct differences.
A special part
of the cerebral
hemispheres that is
not visible from the
outside or exterior
side of the cerebral
hemisphere is
called limbic lobe.
So the limbic lobe
comprises of cingulate
cortex, this purple
color surrounding
the corpus callosum
here in the middle,
and also hippocampus
that's buried inside
the hippocampal
gyrus, as well as the
amygdala that's also
at the very medial
aspect of the temporal
lobe. So these are
the main structures
of the limbic lobe
that is controlling
the emotional responses
of a person. We call
it five Fs, feeling,
feeding, fleeing,
fighting, and ***.
Now let's review the
cerebral hemisphere as
we have introduced
so far. We have our
central sulcus, we have
our lateral sulcus to
divide the cerebral
hemisphere into the
frontal lobe, parietal
lobe, temporal lobe.
And from this hypothetical
line between the
occipital notch and
the parietal occipital
gyrus, we have the
occipital lobe as well. So
these different
lobes is in charge of
different functions. As
you can see, the frontal
lobe, we talked about
the motor function,
as well as the social
behavior for the prefrontal
cortex, and Broca's
area for language.
And for the parietal
lobe, we have this
somatosensory
cortex. We also have
Wernicke's area that's
going across the
parietal lobe and
temporal lobe. And
also, we have the
auditory cortex right
here at the superior
temporal gyrus.
And at the medial
temporal lobe, we also
see half the limbic
structures that's related
to memory and emotions.
At the back occipital
lobe is mainly for
the visual cortex.
The pelvic lobe
buried inside the
brain right next to
the corpus callosum
and the diencephalon
in the middle
is related with
learning and higher
cognitive function
like emotions.
We went into the
details of introducing
the fall brain,
especially the cerebral
hemisphere. here,
and we talked
about different
lobes at the cerebral
cortex, and also the
limbic structures.
Next, we're going
to talk about
the diencephalon,
brainstem,
cerebellum, and
basal ganglia.
Previously, we mentioned
that the diencephalon
including three
major structures. So
this is our diencephalon.
It has thalamus,
hypothalamus,
and pineal gland.
Although it
doesn't look very
big, diencephalon is very
important for the
brain functions.
So thalamus is a big
relay center for the
sensory information
to be transmitted from
the body to the
cerebral cortex. and the
hypothalamus is
super important for
maintaining homeostasis
like controlling the
autonomic functions
and the pineal gland is
controlling the
circadian rhythms in our
body so you know we
got sleepy during the
night and be very
energetic during the day.
Now let's look
more closely to
the brainstem.
This is again a
mid-sagittal slice
of the brain.
As you can see, the
brainstem has the three
major structures.
This is the midbrain
with those two
bumps. You know,
those are the two
colliculi. Those
are the landmarks.
And then pons,
you have the spatial
pons, that's the big
belly. And then you
have medulla. So medulla
is the lower part of
the brainstem that's
connecting to the spinal
cord. So these three
major structures are
very important with the
general functions of,
you know, vital to
the life, really
important for survival
controlling breathing
cardiovascular function
closely related to the
autonomic control we
talked about the
hypothalamus is the one of
the big centers controlling
autonomic output
and the hypothalamus
has to go along the
brain stem you know
pretty much dorsolateral
aspects of the
brainstem going along to
reach the spinal cord
to control you know
the sympathetic chain
and you know control
the parasympathetic
functions too so
the autonomic control
coming down from
the hypothalamus are
reaching the spinal
cord passing through
the entire brainstem
We're just going to
introduce briefly the
basal ganglion structures
here. You're going
to have a special
lecture later on to talk
about each individual
areas within the basal
ganglion, which is
actually distributed across
cerebrum, midbrain,
and diencephalon. so
all of these different
nuclei are working
concertedly so to
initiate the movement and
thoughts and also
related to the reward
sensation so after a long
time Parkinson's patients
a lot of time to receive
like experiencing
the dementia, so they
have cognitive decline
and also a problem
with their emotions.
Greenstem is
also the home
for the 12
cranial nerves,
actually besides
the first two, so
it's a home for the
10 cranial nerves.
These cranial nerves
have been introduced
in great details by
Dr. Jason Burke. Please
review his lecture
if you don't remember
these cranial nerves
and their functions.
And because it's a
brainstem connecting
the brain and the
spinal cord, you can
see the long tracks
of ascending, which
means from the body
to the brain, as well
as descending, which
means from the brain
out to the body
those long tracks all
passing the brain
stem so brain stem is
extremely important
for these long traps
another important
function in the brain
stem is to maintain
consciousness we
have this reticular
activating system within
this entire brainstem
and so you know
it projects all
these signals the
neurotransmitters
throughout the entire brain
to control the level
of consciousness
so basically promoting
awareness of the
environment so a
brainstem lesion patient
usually have the
problem with the they
might be alive but
they are not really
aware of the surroundings
so they can be at
the vegetative state
or in a coma state
okay last part of
the brain cerebellum
cerebellum is meaning
small brain or little
brain in Latin We know
that it's related to
the motor coordination,
and if we try to
learn how to ride a
bike or swim, we would
need the cerebellum
to function normally.
The reason it's
a small brain is
because it also has
two hemispheres,
kind of a mini-sized
brain, but it does not
have the complexity of
the cerebrum. In recent
years, the cerebellum
has been studied a
little more and was
discovered that it's
related to the limited
sensory function as well
as learning memory and
cognitive function.
So cerebellum works
with the spinal cord
to help control the
motor coordination.
Okay, last but not
least, the spinal cord.
The spinal cord is
connecting with the
brainstem here is
a home for the long
tracts. As you can see
how much white matter
surrounding the gray
matter, you imagine
a lot of long tracts
are located here.
So for the gray
matter, we can
divide them into
the dorsal horn,
a ventral horn, and
a lateral horn here
at the thoracic
cord so the dorsal
horn received
information from the body
so from the you know
skin limbs wherever
it can either send
the information up
through the brain
stem to the brain or
send the information
locally within the
spinal segment and
then innervate the
ventral horn motor
neurons to contract
the muscle. So this
internal arc is
called spinal
reflexes. So the spinal
reflexes are very
useful for diagnosis.
Showing here in this
cartoon, the doctor
is using a small
hammer to hit this
underneath the knee joint.
It's called patellar
reflex. In the
normal person, the
patellar reflex will
not be this exaggerated
to lift the leg and
the foot to kick
the doctor's chin.
But when you have
pathological conditions,
then there is a
possibility there is a
hyperreflexia. So this
deep tendon reflex
can be exaggerated.
And that's one of
the hallmarks of the
upper motor neuron
lesions. You're
going to go through
those in the future.
We mentioned about the
lateral horn in the
thoracic region.
This is where the
sympathetic preganglionic
neurons are located.
So spinal cord is
an important release
station for the
autonomic nervous system.
And from these
lateral horn neurons,
the cells can send
out the axons to the
periphery. And for
the parasympathetics,
it's not only
located in the spinal
cord, in the sacral
segment of the
spinal cord, but
also located in the
brainstem. This is
part of the medulla.
All right, let's
review the second part
of the lecture.
So the first part,
we talked about the
cerebrum, and the
second part, we were
talking about the
diencephalon,
which including the
hypothalamus, thalamus,
and pineal gland.
So thalamus is our
relay station mainly
for the sensory
information, and
hypothalamus is for
the autonomic function
control and maintain
the homeostasis.
Brainstem is for
the autonomic system
as well as the
cranial nerves, lung
tracts, and also
important information
about keeping the
person conscious,
so the ascending
reticular formation.
And then
cerebellum is for
the motor coordination.
Spinal cord is for
these lung tracts
receiving the body's
information and sending
the signals to control
the body movement.
All right, let's
do the final
review of
today's lecture.
So you have to
understand the central
nervous system
is comprised of
brain and spinal
cord in general.
And then brain,
of course, can be
subdivided into different
parts, including
forebrain, cerebellum,
and brain stem.
And forebrain,
including the cerebral
hemisphere and
diencephalon. Brainstem
includes the midbrain,
pounds, and medulla.
And then for the
cerebral hemisphere
or cerebrum, you
could further
divide it into the
cerebral cortex,
basal ganglion, and
the limbic structures.
For diencephalon,
you could also
further divide
them into thalamus,
hypothalamus,
and pineal gland.
the most complex
part is the cerebral
hemisphere which is
further divided into
the five different
lobes so the limbic
lobe is actually
kind of overlapping
here that with the
limbic structures
this is the end of
the lecture please
make sure you send
me some feedbacks if
you have comments or
suggestions to help
me improve before
i end this lecture
i'd like to emphasize
one more time please
read this book
notice essentials of
the human brain second
edition this is a
called essentials
because it's totally
simplified for medical
students only total 200
pages long with
questions after each
chapter to help you
solidify and recall the
knowledge that's
learned so make sure you
read this book and check
that out it has the
e-version and if you
have any questions
this is my email one
more time and please
email me with questions
comments we could
also meet individually
thank you very much